[Aplausos]
[Música]
alguna vez pidieron algo caro que no
tenían
piensen en lo que dije algo caro con un
gran precio más caro que lo que tenían
significa que ya tienen algo caro pero
que quieren algo todavía más costoso les
voy a contar que todos los aquí
presentes inclusive son vimos una
burbuja de privilegios para empezar
quiero definir qué es la palabra
privilegio es una condición de ventaja
atribuida a una persona al grupo de
personas por el dinero en el sistema
capitalista el capitalismo en su sistema
en el que todo tiene un costo moneda en
el caso argentino el peso este sistema
busca dividir a la sociedad en
diferentes clases por los recursos que
tengan
estos privilegios los adquirimos muchas
veces por no hacer que es por nacer de
un lugar que estás privilegiado si bien
algunas personas pueden conseguirlos por
su propia cuenta la mejor ya nos hacemos
con o sin ellos estos privilegios para
terminar donde estudiamos con quien los
relacionamos y en definitiva quienes
podemos llegar a ser
puede sonar un poco determinista pero
muy difícil modificar el destino que nos
marcan nuestros privilegios o su
carencia
un chico que nace en un hogar sin
privilegios supongamos que es una vieja
está determinado a crecer en la pobreza
con una baja educación y pocos recursos
a recibir probablemente una manera en
alimentación ya crecer probablemente en
un ambiente tal vez violento
qué pasa si vemos un adulto pobre en la
calle
muchas veces nos preguntamos por qué no
trabaja
la primera opción es que haya tenido
problemas en su vida pero la otra opción
es que su educación no haya sido buena
desde niño y nunca se ha podido
conseguir trabajo
y ahora ustedes estarán preguntando por
qué recibir tanta educación es
importante luego que se nos abre la
puertas al mundo del trabajo sin
educación la gente no nos aceptaría
pensando en esto sentí que me gustaría
compartir mis privilegios pero eso es
imposible el ser humano no puede
deshacerse de ellos
nos acompañarán toda nuestra vida van a
marcar el camino que recorremos y
requerimos abandonar todo lo que tenemos
no cambia nuestra educación de esta
capacidad de poder recuperar estos
privilegios
entonces qué podemos hacer para
construir una sociedad más igualitaria
no es igualando los privilegios porque
si todos los tienen en el fondo nadie
los tiene
yo creo que si compartimos recursos y
también compartimos oportunidades
podemos dar lugar nos hacía mucho más
justa y equitativa
la apertura de este nuevo camino a las
clases menos privilegiados
para disminuir los niveles de pobreza
sin que las clases ricas se verán
necesariamente perjudicados con sólo dar
un poco podríamos utilizar los recursos
disponibles para tocar y ofrecer empleos
dignos a sectores mucho más amplios de
la sociedad
sin duda además de la pobreza
disminuiría las injusticias la violencia
que sufrimos a diario
pero como podríamos llevar esta idea a
cabo pensemos por ejemplo en la
educación es probable que nosotros
muchos de nosotros
vamos a seguir en estudios superiores o
sea los dejamos seguidos desde aquí
podríamos usar un poco de nuestro tiempo
para espacios educativos formales e
informales
también se podrá coger sistemas de becas
para hacer que cada vez más personas
puedan sostener sus estudios
ahora bajamos al mundo del trabajo si
nosotros accedemos a una posición
gerencial o decisiones importantes en
una empresa podemos fomentar el ingreso
de personas que no hayan tenido tantas
oportunidades
en cuanto a la salud todos sabemos que
alguien sin salud podría morir o quizás
estar limitando sus oportunidades para
mejorar la salud se pueden apoyar
algunas ongs organizaciones no
gubernamentales para que mejoren los
equipos y construcción hospitales además
se puede presionar el gobierno para que
cambie las políticas de salud como ven
en prácticamente es cada aspecto de
nuestra vida podemos colaborar
participar transformar nuestro entorno
sin dejar de ser quienes somos
además
son privilegiados esta es nuestra base
para que cada vez más personas puedan
mejorar este es el poder que cada uno
tiene dentro no abandonar lo que tenemos
sino utilizar todo lo que nos dieron
para ofrecer un futuro mejor a los demás
[Aplausos]